l'épisode d'aujourd'hui tourne et que
l'on en dise est exclusivement avec les
ordis et puis surtout avec le fantôme
green qui est vraiment super jours
à
ok ça lui aujourd'hui je donne rendez
vous dans une station de ski et je sais
une station de ski sauf que là on est en
plein été il fait super beau il fait
super chaud pour parler du bonheur
disent on va tester son ordis du point
de vue de la photo et de la vidéo
on va regarder s'il intéressant de
regarder si c'est le smartphone tant
attendu le photophone tant attendu dans
le milieu de gamme
à priori oui moi en tout cas je n'ai pas
essayé je vous en ai parlé aux durs donc
là on va les tester ensemble
mais avant toute chose il faut
[Musique]
c'est faux
m
[Musique]
et drôlement bien la stabilisation la
thur c'est super stabiliser c'est hyper
smooth
[Musique]
8h15 donnait téléphérique on est large
de chez large
je ne sais pas j'espère juste qu'on va
la voir ce que je te dis qu'on est large
mais ça se trouve on n'est pas l'heure
du tout il est haut
17h32 on est large de chaînage on va la
voir le téléphérique
[Musique]
du sommet du sancy c'est en auvergne
dans le puy de dôme
c'est juste le spot le plus ouf les
verts vous avez une station de ski est
là vous avez un spot avec démarche de
dengue 812 marche
voilà comme ça je peux tout filmé et là
je dois reconnaître que franchement
séance est levée sur les caméras et
smartphones parce que c'est vachement
stable ou même sur la caméra de sel
philo rendu est vachement beau on a un
panorama qui est juste incroyable à 360
degrés c'est magnifique et most hid
parce que c'est la gueule je vous emmène
dans un spot qui est juste qui est juste
géniale ici au sommet du sancy le temps
exceptionnel je traîne au film avec les
caméras avant duo nordiste et je dois
franchement reconnaître que je sais je
le fais je vous ai présenté le jour de
nouveaux modèles c'est le fantôme green
juste sublime j'avais pas testé le aux
nordistes
j'avais beaucoup entendu parler puis
jallet est de tester puis de voir si la
caméra était à la hauteur de sa
réputation comme de photos de vidéos
je dois avouer que je suis franchement
impressionnés et une vraie stabilisation
à l'avant à l'arrière probablement une
stabilisation logiciel vu le prix de ce
smartphone si vous voulez un bon
photophone milieu de gamme pas trop cher
le aux nordistes
c'est vraiment une petite bombe et ça je
peux que vous recommander ce qui est
génial c'est que vous avez plein de
modes différents dessus vous avez bien
évidemment le fameux mode portrait vous
avez du timelapse vous pouvez faire des
photos en panorama vous avez même un
mois d'ouverture
vous avez un mode professionnel pour
ensuite aller chercher un peu plus faire
ce que vous voulez puis moi ce qui
m'impressionne toujours avancer la
stabilisation de cette bécane j'ai pas
si vous regardez mes tests n'aura lieu
général la stabilisation avec moi si
elle est pas bonne ça se voit
immédiatement ça bouge tous les côtés
c'est vraiment dégueulasse
là c'est vraiment top hélas dans un spot
comme celui là je te reconnaître que
c'est quand même tout particulièrement
bluffant parce que l'assistant cg stop
c'est magnifique
magnifique là le aux nordistes je te
reconnaître que là dessus et me lasse
pas de voir enfin des petits filtres
comme source nachat là comme sa petite
souris je suis vraiment top comme m en
petit lapin en catcheur masqué en petit
chien je sais pas ce que c'est c'est un
peu bizarre c'est louche mais il y en a
plein et fait la classe bon bien sûr
vous avez du scan de documents fin je
dois reconnaître que du point de vue de
la photo c'est franchement un smartphone
qui est vraiment complet et je ne peux
que vous recommander
j'essayais de me casser la gueule
par contre la crainte que j'ai c'est du
point de vue de l'audio parce que là il
ya un petit peu de vent on va se rendre
compte quand vous avez regardé la vidéo
si on l'entend trop si le son est
vraiment dégoûtant ou si ça peut le
faire
ça ça c'est un peu le point
d'interrogation il ya peu le camoufler
avec ma main mais je suis pas sûr ça
marche et que ça le fasse
en attendant je suis plutôt content se
trouve cool l'affichage à l'écran est
bien la qualité est là avec le coche
c'est pas mal surtout ce que j'adore
c'est la couleur de smartphones je
trouve qu'il est vraiment beau pour coup
aux normes ont vraiment un gain par
rapport je sais déjà dit dans une
passante vidéo mais rapport aux autres
smartphones qu'on pouvait trouver avant
là ils vont beaucoup plus loin et ça
c'est génial
c'est pour moi ton bouquet chérie tu as
mis quoi dedans comme fleur savais pas
que tu mérites
[Musique]
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
en tout cas moi je trouve que ce
photophone est plutôt cool voilà je suis
convaincu je trouve que le honneur dit
ça fait bien le job je pense que je suis
très très beau comme ça plutôt bon
smartphone plutôt cool j'espère que ça
vous aura plu dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous directement dans la section
commentaires dites moi si vous pensez
que le aux nordistes est à la hauteur
vieillotte notamment dites moi si vous
pensez qu'il écoulait ce qui pourrait
vous tenter est ce que vous pourriez
acheter sonore des sites yahoo comme ça
il en courant est ce que vous pourriez
acheter ces honneurs 10s kivu tox est ce
qui vous ferait plaisir
la grande course vous marquez tout ça
bien évidemment commentaires on reste
connectés
l'histoire des cds jolie pousse à vous
abonner sans plus parler de take 2 cuil
innovants et là je continue mon shoot
oui